je rends compte bled je tombe amoureuse
de lui on traîne en somme maman exit les
mailles cousin je dis bah ouais est ton
mari qui t'attend tu veux tu peux rester
ici mais moi je suis plus tard il a tout
plaqué pour elle et se retrouve en
france avec plus rien c'est très mal vu
ici le mariage organisé une française
oh non
veut pas rester ici je vous retourne
dans mon pays
sofia selim c'est du passé c'est bon on
parle plus
tu t'es fait j'attends ta langue il
s'est marié avec sofia et sa place est
en france pas ailleurs
attends c'est ça la maison de samada je
voudrais acheter pour faire une maison
d'hôtes où je suis pas une chèvre je
suis pas une vache suis pas avoir de
recours au 21ème siècle
je suis libre
si toi je la rendrai pas symphonique
non je fais maintenant comment d'ivoire
6 le court derrière